you know I don't really have armrest ever
when I film wow how's it feel too relaxed I
feel like it's going to limit my engagement and
my sharpness you look very calm very I know I'm
out of my realm citizens of the reject Nation
I have rewatched the entire Goosebump show and
read all the books in preparation for this
movie wow that's true dedication that's true
dedication not a lie at [Music] all I also did
the same definitely didn't just watch it as a
kid and forget everything I saw when I was a
child The Nostalgia is going to play heavily
on us what are we watching they watching the
Goosebumps movie I've heard it's a fun one
Aaron you're the only other person I know that
hasn't seen it are you excited yes is because
it has Jack black and has black in his name is
that why you picked me save the racist jokes
for bab I thought that okay that's you that's
a you thing one thing to play off your racist
joke I take the power back if I can make the
racist job yeah yeah now it's empowering it is
can ladies and gentlemen you know what to do
leave a like on this video I guess I'm just
all pinked up today like I'm super pink I'm
super pink subscribe click the notification
Bell cuz we got other movies we covering this
month Aon is also covering a bunch with like
terara Andrew it's it's good good month good
month for movies lastly full in watch long
resync with your own copy available for super sex
reject over at our patreon page fre sync up with
your own copy we cover sever things exclusive
the reaction H watchong included this intro is
[Music]
done oh this feels like it's going
to be like some fun spooky fun yeah
the the music's giving like fun spooky I
don't know reminds me of Haunted Mansion
Madison Delaware wow Mom are you positive
that there were't any other places looking
for vice principles it's Holly from the
office Amy Ryan do you have you Michael
scottw girl wife lady and that's the kid
from 13 Reasons Why yeah whatever H's
[Music] back fun vo I I know the feeling of having
a new neighbor and wondering who's there I am that
I am that creepiest I am you hear that no I don't
hear anything exactly hi from New York get my
sister Gail a special guest my nephew Z oh my God
the quirky loud sister oh it's just a beautiful
boy and thank God cuz you were such an ugly baby
there it is he's handsome now it's not like he's
going to go ugly handsome and then back to ugly
actually it happens more often than you think this
is from my new signature men's line go your shirt
it's limited edition so you're not going to see a
lot of men wearing that PCH yeah I know I can't
imagine anyone would be wearing it so limited
[Music] edition smooth love when that
happen love interest Girl Next Door
how long was the drive from New York no I
can just tell by the pretty hat that you
have it's actually a gift from my aunt it's
also a gift for me and everyone who gets to
see you wearing it I like sarcastic
[__] strangers I got to go good
talk there he is there he is you stay away
from my daughter you stay away from me we
won't have a problem goofy but I would also
be a little scared you that had intense eye
contact well just met our neighbor oh Mr
Shivers yeah he moved to town a few years
ago very mysterious very sexy I love his scent
it's like mint and Bo peculiar I remember that
day Papa maybe Mr Shivers could be your
new daddy daddy Shivers you ready honey
you okay um yeah just found some more baby
pictures I really did look like baby gollem
masking your pain with sarcasm how unrelatable
people don't do that new friends new friends
what do you think you're doing I'm going
to work going to do some educating some
administrating I love her so much she's such
a good actress yeah she's awesome not sure
walking in with the vice principal is the play
give me a 60c head start so I at least have a
chance you promise you'll give it a shot you know
I can't promise you that a come on embarrass him
I promise all right come on you're better
than that 60 second start now 60 59 58 I
hope she has the same class with Mr shiver's
daughter okay let's settle down okay cool okay
oh you're the Corky comedic best friend okay
am so happy to introduce you to our new vice
principal Miss Cooper and I hope that you
show her the same that you show me Bowser
who did that I'll whoop your ass you can't
say that yeah I can you're in the room with
me I thought we the ru not until we make
a handshake then you get the these rules
are so complicated you taking anyone to the dance
okay no hey we should go together no no not like
together together dance together or anything
although that could work you know we get the
crowd into it you know and then go split off with
different girls yeah that's how they would read
it I like how this cinematography has
progressively gotten darker and grayer
someone there did I scare you no really
because you jump like 10 ft high is she
an actual daughter or like creature cuz the way
they capture her like for povs feel like she's
not a human is she a werewolf so is there anything
like fun to do around here okay there is one thing
that I like to do eat humans come with me if you
want to [Music] live damn he loged out getting a
next door neighbor who's like a a teenager you a
cute girl teenager friend like oh my God that's
like the dream when you're a teenager the dream
this guy's like living a movie are you taking me
someone to kill me I'm just curious I'm playing
it by year she means that I don't think she's
human I think she's something more Hannah yes
Zach Follow The Stranger into the woods she's
a bird come on scaredy cat we're almost there
might be a clue scurity cat you might be right
the werewolf thing think you're on or something
by the way if my theories don't come true I'm
going to be pissed off at the movie it's how I
operate as a viewer if I'm not right the movie
is bad watch this [Music] whoa o what a find wow
how the hell is this just in the middle of the
woods how do the lights still work City didn't
turn the power off in this place they built it
years ago but then they ran out of money now it
just sits here but still gets power yeah that's
a great question eron it's a great question
why did you move to Madison my mom said to me
Zach if you can live anywhere in the the world
where would it be can I please move to Madison
Delaware that' be my dream are you always the
sarcastic always no that's a strong word not
always usually makes you likable it's just been
me and my mom since my dad died last year so
yeah I'm sorry oh my god dude you can totally
get her with the sympathy who's your dead dad
get the [Laughter] pity how do we get down oh I'll
fly us down I mean it's nighttime so she can't be
a werewolf it's only on full depends on the moon
what yeah it depends on the moon yeah you know I'm
probably going to take out the trash on Tuesdays
and Thursdays so you know you feel like creeping
up on someone that works for me I can take your
trash out too if you want I'll keep that in mind
scaredy cat Hannah what are you doing out here
I'm so sorry I'm just smoking cracked this is
your last warning you stay stay away from us
or something very bad will happen I believe
you there are some very interesting choices to
to capture like stuff in in their first person
point of view you don't see that too often because
they do it interchangeably between Hannah and Jack
Black allow to can lock me up all the time she is
not human she ain't human uhoh oh my God he thinks
he thinks domestic violence is happening what's
going on plot twist it really is just domestic
violence what I heard a scream is
hand okay there was no scream you
didn't hear anything get out of here with
the last scream you'll ever hear would be
I really like Jack Black's performance
yeah it's different for him never seen
him do something like that count 911 hi
yes uh I live on Monroe um uh it's an
emergency I think yeah maybe of possibly a
a domestic disturbance I don't know Bad News
Bears you're under
arrest I love that keep it we're not there yet
that's so funny it's a domestic disturbance
absolutely right strange because I've been here
alone all night and I haven't heard a thing what
is this Transatlantic accent he's doing yeah
he's doing it from like a different time period
Anna's my daughter and she's been staying with
me for a while while her mother sorted a few
things out with her new husband she flew back
to London yesterday morning that's creative as
[__] mhm thank you for your time I'm sorry
for the disturbance npe that puts a wrench
in your [Music] story oh it's a movie surround
sound I didn't know being an audio file was a
crime who is she she's my
favorite one so clever that's
funny thank you so much for stopping by and
bringing your delightful son and the police
the police hate coming into the home of
an upstanding citizen such as yourself
really sorry I obviously you're seeing
he senses something chares nervous you're
sweating way too suspicious my friend
up tase him I'll tase him you're so
eager tell me you don't believe him
surround sound seriously Zach enough go
home all right K coming through and don't worry
it's going to be all about Zach tonight so we went
out to Sushi on Wednesday and we both ordered
the chicken teriyaki which like wa is Amy Ryan
not going to be the main character with is going
to be this woman I feel like she's going to come
back she's the administrator of the school she
says stop dating losers and never go on a plane I
knew it you know I I totally forgot I have a huge
test on Monday that I got to study for don't come
in my room oh okay don't don't do that not cuz
you're boring or anything where are the girls uh
yeah about that I just said that to get you over
here I need your help so there are no girls well
there is one girl a m he can say it yeah well
there's no black people in Madison so no one
can hear them how do you know this guy's going
to leave I called him and pretended to be the
cops and ask him to come to the station dude you
can get in big trouble for that it's actually just
a written warning it's God damn he was hit his
head on the ground Jesus a WWE over here what the
hell it's fun how they're painting
Jack Black like he's a bad
guy whoa where' you learn that Dad no YouTube
oh that makes more sense like that more than
played video games tell I'm a good shooter stay
here and watch the driveway wait here by myself
yes champ you're the lookout if sh comes back
and Just Give Me A Sign like I know use his
name as an insult [Laughter] This creepy it's
her it's a warning sign you're in the second
[Music] acted what the H man you're supposed to
be the lookout yeah that's not going to change
I just be the lookout you know in here you
had one job let me explain something to you
Zacharias you know they say teenagers have no
fear of death well not me okay I was born with
the gift of fear okay I remember being for
being pushed on a swing and thinking this
is how it ends oh bear traps oh my God who puts
bear traps in their basement I mean seriously oh
my my God someone who has a monster problem the
Scarecrow Walks at Midnight the ghost next door
Night of the Living Dummy That's a classic the
Abominable Snowman of Pasadena my grandma losing
Pasadena and I stopped visiting after reading
this book that's not far from us why are these
books locked how would lock a book maybe there's
like a a key or something we can unlock it with
don't do that look at this don't unlock that
book is for a reason now let's get back to W oh
no Zach hey that was their plan for the dance did
you unlock a book yeah I did I'll put
it back where it belongs and we'll be
out of your hair look here it is no
don't open it oh what have you done
[Music] uh-oh oh interesting Who ah this
makes a lot more sense now [Music] okay
whoa why would you write
these books RL [Music] Stein
W there's like a Jumanji Night at
the Museum Vibe yeah yeah totally
totally it's not a bad looking effect not
bad for almost 10 years ago man yeah
right what's going on nobody make a
sound you had one job he had two jobs and
you filled them both oh [Music] [__] he's
an Andrew and Roxy other's opening on their own
what I thought you need the lock to do that come
on come on movie play by your own rules what are
the rules of your universe that's the Abominable
Snowman you don't get that nickname by accident
and it just crawled out of a book that doesn't
just happen Zach I'm going after Hannah hey
that's the Abominable Snow Man of Pasadena to
you would have been better if you didn't fumbled
that yep but you mumbled earlier so now we're
even what is she going to do read
the story I mean the plan to like
capture him put him back right yeah just
clamp him up he can't be killed uhoh look
above that a Skittle why don't you look
to where it fell from it's candy uhoh
CER
damn you [Music] strong a that's cute
no you don't understand the only way to
stop them is to suck him back into the
book The Suck back in no I'm not close
enough oh he seems so harmless until
he looks at you those eyes what are
you doing just open the book just
wait why don't you just leave you
clearly don't want to be here all lot
of timing got time oh no what are you
[Music] doing oh my God does anyone know
how to play hockey here let get the walk
yes come [Applause]
[Music]
on
I like the idea quite a bit though teenagers
in Peril with the meta commentary of like
the Goosebumps coming to life yeah so you
get the Nostalgia of the older people who
did read it and then with the kids nowadays
and books usually rob about kids it's very
clever what is happening I think
ARL Stein's behind them Papa got
the book Papa's going to get mad
like I die yep damn why does it
look disturbing when it happens it's so
sad oh is he turning into ink [Music]
yeah this is sad wonder what the myth is going
to be around it like did he create it or all
of you in the car now I'm going to guess he's RL
Stein [Laughter] just a hunch you're RL Stein RL
who I don't know who that [Laughter] is just as
well cuz his books suck you're playing on his EO
I'm so confused you see the endings coming from
a mile away it's like stop trying to be Stephen
King man h no that the worst thing you could
say let me tell you something about Steve Kings
and I've sold way more books than him but nobody
ever talks about that okay way more books dad go
what if we're just watching one of his books right
now what if we're in the book yeah there's a book
within a book hey hey what happens now you go home
you put on your PJs you get your blanket you go
napnap in the morning this will all just feel like
a bad dream Dad wait there's no time start packing
we're moving again is it just his actual daughter
n she's a werewolf maybe he married a werewolf or
like a mermaid who developed legs and now walks
amongst us humans not a normal family now go get
your things I'm so over this teenagers maybe she's
been a teenager for a very very very long time old
team it's actually his wife I could have killed
you that was a terrible throat when I was younger
I suffered from terrible allergies that kept
me indoors so I created my own friends monsters
demons that that happens and they became real to
me and then one day it became real to everyone my
monsters literally leapt off the page as long as
the books remain locked were safe but when they
open you've just seen what happens I love that he
still portrays it like he's a like a Storyteller
like he's almost talking to the audience in a
way keep the manting plants away from the bug
eyed aliens no uhoh not him hello Papa yes oh it's
is it who I think it is the dumy the how long's
it been you're so creepy as a kid Slappy it's so
nice to see you did you miss me course I missed
[Music] you oh no so what what's the plan friend
you must have brought me out for something fun
terrorize the locals destroy the town Let's Get
Silly is that ham kind of sounds like him going to
destroy Madison and I couldn't do it without you
oh shs you giv me oh what's the word Goosebumps
wait remember Jack Black oh you're right you're
trying to put me back in don't be silly I know
when you're lying to me Papa he creepy you think
yeah you've made oh no I think it's time I started
pulling the strings in this relationship tonight
is going to be the best story you've ever written
oh no uhoh so slopp is our main antagonist
he's the leader of them oh no why would you
just keep all your books right there why don't
you keep him in a safe or [Laughter] something
a freshen up I don't remember the Gnomes from the
oh really good effects yeah oh they're cracking
their their necks and their hands damn that's a
lot of gnomes that is a little unsettling yeah
break them do get something that's on your
side friendly nope nope nope as soon as he said
that immediately no not friendly definitely not
friendly look it looks like clamation that's
cool yeah to my face definitely [Applause] not
yeah just smash them kick just smash all of them
get us a gold actually like knock knocked out
yeah oh my God no this feels like Army
of [Music] Darkness thank you thank you
you can be more effective throwing them in
the oven oh yeah you become Your Own Worst
Enemy Welcome to Hell oh no can they
reassemble oh no oh it's smart they're
reversing it wa it's clever timing I
like how it looks actually in camera
why couldn't you've written stories about
rainbows and unicorns because that doesn't
sell 400 million copies oh domestic no
worldwide it's still very impressive shut
up that's why Netflix always touts those
numbers oh she is human yeah I guess so homeboy
lives very under the radar for someone that
wealthy then again did you know what ARL Stein
looked like prior to this movie I did he used
to introduce Goosebumps or do the epilog one
of them well I forgot why is he doing this so
there's no way to get the monsters back inside
it's Slappy's Revenge Slappy's Revenge that's a
good title like he said it I was like good title
what is that thing I come in peace I just want
to read you a bedtime story sir shut your mouth
okay CU that's not going to stop me you've been
relieved of your duties now what are [Music]
those oh no it does a good job though even
if you haven't if you don't remember or know
the the Goosebumps creatures and stuff they
easily inform you yeah like all it takes us
to see what the creature does really quick to
understand what it is yeah gets me curious
to figure out the other stories yeah sure
you'll make your time for that oh my God it's a
floating dog [Music] uhoh it's an alien dog alien
puppy that's spooky damn they froze the town
I just love sets yeah that's really cool you
just don't get sets production design building
it this would be in the volume if it was made
today if if you wrote The Monsters off the page
then maybe there's a way you could write them
back on do you have any idea how many stories
i' have to ride to capture every monster I've
ever created I already have carpal tunnel
in both hands this is when Chad gbt comes in
handy okay well then we got to get you
to a computer so you can start writing
all right there's a look there's a computer
store right here get you break in why don't
you just write a new character that take
care of all the other characters yeah the
Superman of to Wrangle them all in if
I write on anything else it won't work
I need my typewriter that typewriter
is special it has a soul of its own
just write Goosebumps the book the lead
character takes care of all the other
Goosebumps yeah school dance his typewriters
at the school dance hell yeah that's
what all the kids are into drugs and
typing oh that's where the mom went
to the school dance wait look [Music]
out holy moly what is that is
that the plant saw earlier plant
monster oh no that's a giant fly a
giant fly about a giant bra man pre
mantis
oh my God it's a it's a drunk playing pray
[Music] [Applause] [Music] mantis right
[Music] to it feels like a b movie
sci-fi horror when like you know big
big bug creature attacks the town yeah you
have to come up with something so freaky
just have a neck for it I guess oh no my
wagon ear my wagon ear you cut yourself
is my face messed up yeah big time you
look exactly the same make out perfect
time oh nope that's a werewolf yep I do wish some
more of the creatures were more practical though
yeah the sets are but the creatures all CG yeah
like I feel like this could have been practical
and it is not age well yeah the the Snowman looked
better the Werewolf of fif swamp he can snow my
scent it's not working I have
to that boy smells strong Jack Black
brings a lot to this yeah he's on our TA
oh no oh
no get me up oh no no no keep
[Music] going mom or is it the aunt I think
it's the YT yep I'm okay I'm still okay she
be perfect to date RL Stein this is the back
of my store I didn't know where else to go I
can't get a hold of your mother or the cops or
anyone yep I saw it in his face immediately he's
bewildered I'm lorine hello arel Stein we owe
you a great dead of gratitude yeah oh lorine
lorine lorine we don't have time I need you
to go to the police station and tell them to
meet us oh did you want to exchange numbers is
that a good timeing yes dang that girl making
his Goosebump for know they're going to Goose
hump does everyone get it sex please you're the
SC cat wait wait wait wait wait wait hold on
it's okay it's just a statue all right you're
fine it's not just a statue have you not seen
Doctor Who it's a weeping angel don't blink
it's C on your jacket my hero make out perfect
time in between danger right in front of her
dad do it champ interrupt oh D are you right
maybe come on she something she's something
knew she wasn't human knew she wasn't human
oh she's dead she's a ghost what are you a
ghost yeah yeah totally I'm how
about anology you just witness
zombies oh maybe she doesn't know
oh oh my God classic zombies gouls
is hten get GS and zombies confused
are they one in the same I don't know
I thought ghouls were like an offshoot
of ghost calling all cops calling all the
cops can anyone hear me I can hear
oh he is still there okay Sergeant
Slappy Sergeant Slappy he is like Chucky
you're don't do it don't say it dummy you
said wow they're just there on Q Hannah doesn't
know that she doesn't know what that she's not
real she thinks she's a person okay not not
just some figment of your imagination how
could wow it's messed up you have no idea
how lonely it's been until Hannah I wrote
her in such a way that she thinks she's real
and she is real to me Zach but the Moonlight
reveals it after my dad died I should everyone
out too maybe we can both start over if we're
alive tomorrow no that's a little tragic yeah
or if we're going to come across the Dilemma
of if he has to put all the characters
back that includes her as well or is it
going to find a way to save her how way you
just don't write yourself like the hottest
woman I was just thinking that just write
yourself a really hot wife multiple hot
wives monster have invaded Madison
they they've blocked every road out
of town they they've torn down the
cell towers how do they still have
power good question he's right it's
the Boogeyman and he's picking his
nose who the hell are you guy hope a
creature snatches him there's a giant
bug and it's hitting everybody's
cars yeah it's getting old dude no
seriously that was actually a really great
there are L Stein's monsters but we need
to buy him time to write and don't worry
he's a very quick writer the night was cold
cold was the [Laughter] [Music] night Come
Close don't be shy you don't want to miss the
show wow wa my god he has an army it's Easter
egg [Applause] [Music] Central it plays out like
a quirky Goosebump story which is kind of neat
there's there's other really clever about it it
could be a better movie but it's still really
it's still really like I I do appreciate its
cleverness a lot it's far from great but it's fun
you please no save her so you can date the popular
girl oh my God that's your
maneuver you're going to get
ripped a sh I [Laughter] know is way stronger than
you oh okay whoa what is something do he have
silver on him I think he just bit him I think
his teethes he have a silver tooth yeah Super
Teeth oh uming I have a ton of cavities when
I was T didn't brush my teeth for a whole
year it's so hot you saved my life CH it's
actually champ oh she did call him Chum
earlier oh hell [Music] yeah God see he
practical but that one you could have [Laughter]
C are you okay yeah than come with me she looks
hotter as a ghost right right
Aaron youever seen [Laughter]
a it's like Space Jam a new Legacy if all
the characters were attacking people I've
been running away from people my whole life I
was so angry at the real world that I created
these terrible monsters I'm not mad anymore did
RL sign approve this like the real life RL sign
he's actually suing it's been a loss for three
years like I don't like the way you're portr
[Music] me man they get a lot of mileage out
of this uh what are they called CGI uh Human
Centipede not human CED called PR mtis
there we go [Laughter] [Music] yeah oh
no that's a [Music] bomb get him
oh clever clever clever the old
[Music] Switcheroo holy
crap oh Papa you left without saying goodbye
trying to hide from me oh looks weird turned
your back on me locked me up imprisoned me
in the pages of a book do like that they
give a more personal relationship between
Slappy and ARL Stein say hello to my gous
friend it's the problem that H
everyone don't let it touch you
oh my God I don't know why something about
this movie maybe imagine Jack Black is the
Joker yeah it's he's doing something
that sounds like Mark Hill for Slappy
yeah dude while you're at it man write yourself
a oh my God all right we have to finish the book
okay they can't kill their creator can they sure
they can yeah my goal is to kill
God one day you watch me get it
done they're coming what are we going
to do finish it Zach not going to lie
I don't like this champ guy he's kind
of annoying it's the only one I don't
like again the end there not like
Charming any fight no about to find
out that's a real Ferris wheel yeah
it's a real Forest too's a SE belt
in this thing there's no way they feel like I
was Whimsical part of the movie that I just
can't believe you believe all the monsters I
believe everything else but like we've all been on
a ferris wheel soy be like it's like crushing on
the ground it's like yeah hell no second their
seat hits the around here they go flying wait
what are you waiting for come on open the book
what all the monsters except one oh yeah there's
something that you need to know and you're not
going to believe open the book Zack no she knows
she knows now means it means be suck on a shelf
some place forever you know how many sweet 16s
can one girl have a manstein you're stupid
can't just write her aging take it all open
no bring her back Skybeam even
Goosebumps gets a sky beam hell [Music]
yeah maybe if I hold on to
you tight enough you have
to let go Zach just like you let go of your dead
dad that's the theme of the story let go
Zach Happy's not happy neither is Stein
stupid dumy n Stein you'll be okay I'll
always be in your imagination which is
really where I belong I'm just sad we
never got to share a dance oh this is
actually really [Music] sad I think
they made Dyan manette kiss the air
[Laughter]
I know you loved her those 48 Hours you guys had
it together it's okay we're going to spend the
second movie trying to get her back now that's
probably why she comes back that's probably was
her second movie damn oops bumps to two two bump
bumpier gooses geese we're all happy where happy
High School no trauma at all look how happy of
a high school we are the law still applies no
time [Laughter] off you look great you smell
great is he teaching a literature course or
creative writing class course oh he's teaching
class algebra hey every story ever told can be
broken down into three distinct parts the
beginning the middle and the twist so it's
the twist that's the real RL Stein he's the
new Drama teacher ah so he didn't sue not a
day goes by that I don't think of her but
she'll always be in here and in there and
also right over [Music] there ah a he wrote TST
again they genetically engineered [Laughter]
her let's go does she you get a age nope
there's a lot of questions I have here
still 16 forever forever and ever oh
The Invisible Boy didn't get destroyed
H yep you forgot about [Music]
me nice yeah that's a good twist ending let me
see if there's a post credit scene no I feel
like The Invisible Boy would have been the post
credit scene nerp nerp nerp it's 2015 alrighty
alrighty guys well if you're listening to this
on Apple or Spotify please rate the video my
friend Aaron Alexander and myself their gorgeous
Greg Alba have just watched Goosebumps the 2015
movie because we've both never seen it and you
know algorithm [__] you are it's there's a
show coming out in Disney Plus have you seen
the trailer I heard it's like Riverdale is it
really Goosebumps or something I I don't know I
didn't even know there's a show coming out yeah
it comes out on Disney plus I think and it's
it's supposedly Like A M I don't know some
like darker teen investigation Shenanigans really
like I haven't seen the trailer so I I don't know
but I I've heard some people is Jack coming
back say those things no it's not like it has
nothing to do with this that for some people say
those things both in a good tone and a negative
tone so the exact same sentiments and uh yeah I
think it's going to flop woof because you don't
even know about it do kids still watch you're the
tar you're the Target demographic yep my 28y old
ass It's Made For Me alrighty well um let's talk
about this yeah let's talk about it uh I thought
it was rated out of 10 uh six wow that's a low
rating I mean it was what if what if we added
more numbers in there like like a I can a five
like a 6 point four five you could add a do you
want to add a point do you feel a0 five or do you
not feel a0 five uh I mean like a Pity point5 I
did that I mean I would like I feel like a six
is like it's good I guess if I saw like a 60 on
Rotten Tomatoes I'd be like they just a 60 is a
c so is a six then if we're doing six out of 10
geez that's all it is 60 is 60 out of 100 six of
10 yeah 6 out of 10 it was I think it was fun you
know I appreciated all of the the stuff that was
uh Goose bumpy uh some good vocabulary there wrer
real uh real uh scholar scholar criticism here
uh no I thought it was fun I thought I enjoyed
the music and you know that the performances are
really cool I thought Jack Black really did his
thing was very different from the roles we've
seen him do before uh something that I totes M
goats totes M goats uh something that I didn't
really like too much well I just felt like it
was got a little repetitive towards the middle
section it was just like they're running and
then it's get out of that situation and then it
be running again and I feel like if you're going
to do something like that it should have sort of
a dual purpose you know Advance the characters
Advance the plot at the same time but it felt
like it was just getting from one situation to
the next situation until we got to the end of the
movie um but yeah I mean I there were some laughs
there to be had for sure I thought it was funny
I I like the the two leads including Jack Black
I like the three I didn't really like champ all
that much kind of like yourself um but yeah it
was cool it was it was fun it was fine it didn't
blow me away I don't know it didn't like evoke
any like strong emotions in me but I had fun with
it you know I don't I don't regret watching it it
wasn't bad there were some holes here and there
like logic holes yeah all right what' you think
Greg 9.89 beautiful out of 10 hell yeah I'm
expecting it to go to 11 out of 10 by the time
I'm I'm talking about [Laughter] okay no I I'd I'm
more like a six [Laughter] point yeah at 6.5 part
of me wants to bump it to s just out of effort and
intent the Practical sets were cool when they when
they had them but a lot of the CGI was like yeah
I mean like looking at it in the Le like there's
two ways to look at at a movie right I think like
a good metric is we kind of based look at it like
RW and tomato the thing here some don't people
don't get about rawten tomatoes is like people
often compare the critic score versus the audience
score so so if like a Critic score is low but an
audience score is high mhm people are like see
critics don't know what they're talking about the
difference is critics are watching like a billion
movies all the time and they have a different
type of metric and expectation of film making
standard where an audience scorer the people who
are voting in that audience score for said movie
are the demographic or the audience that they are
aiming to tend to that the movie is aiming to
tend to and they're chiming in to say if they
like really liked it or not you know um so that's
just like my Litt as side so I can so one part of
me is saying that because I'm going all right if
there if the aim is to get like the Goosebumps the
people who liked reading Goosebumps or or watching
Goosebumps I'm sure there's and like really know
the monsters and stuff I can see one scenario
where they just like seeing this [__] pop up
on screen they have fun it's a lot of the Leonard
DiCaprio Once Upon a Time in Hollywood meme of
like oh I know that creature oh I know you know a
lot of that yeah which is like every movie now but
um but yeah there's there's a lot of that that I
think you could enjoy Easter egg the movie and on
top of that too um this one is clearly targeted
because because Goosebumps exists at least when
I was growing up where it was actually it could
be actually really SC at least from a sometimes
you watch some of the clips or whatever you're
like it's cheesy but actually they really commit
to the like it's Camp be but it's still it's
still a Horror Story oh yeah it's still they
still Peril and it's still spooky and creepy um
and some at times unnerving while goofy it it's
still a horror story this is not that this is not
a horror it's got like a backdrop and a setting
so it feels like the target audience is more to
be familyfriendly yeah I could see how you can
get away with more trying to go horror when you're
doing like a a show but when you're trying to sell
them big dollars really trying to sell them on on
on true like kid fear horror I I I don't even feel
like a kid would be scared watching that you know
what I mean no uh it still it still settles more
into like like other than a couple of moments
with like Slappy perhaps the dog like with the
jump scare yeah other than like a little bit like
that there's no actual scene so I feel like the
target audience that they're aiming for perhaps
they do feel satisfied uh I I really don't know
I don't know what the responces I just wanted
to watch it because it's Goosebumps um and and
they and you know algorithm and and it's been
on the list and I and I have wanted to see the
movie so I was like yeah it's perfect timing the
on my personal side I like everything that uh you
said you liked um I do agree I second that Jack
Black I thought really elevated this a lot like
he really I think is a major contributing factor
to what really helped out this this because what
he just have like surprise moments where you just
don't see like a joke come like I love that the
setup of like it's like towards the end of the
movie where I'm like I keep checking in and out
of the film and and they have that line uh when
he's writing he's like he's a fast rider and he's
like the night was cold he just pauses goes cold
was the night he rips it out and starts over that
was so funny it's a great joke it's a really like
great joke and it's visually funny and you need
the right editing for that so like stuff like
that I really enjoyed uh Slappy I thought they
they put the most emphasis on and I will say the
thing that really really undercut the experience
was exactly what you what you pointed out and
that was the thing that stood out to me of like
that's why this movie is kind of becoming numb and
dull is I can't like they there's nothing really
distinguishable about the characters other than
their look or or I guess size you know like oh I
yeah there's a difference between like a ghoul on
ground versus a massive um [__] um what do you
call them God dang what are they pray man the pre
mantis yes there's a difference between a massive
pre mantis and a ghoul on but it is the same
bit over and over again it's very repetitive
they just run into a situation where they're
there it doesn't really seem like there's truly
any physical danger or Stakes because they're
easy to give the slip all the time even when
it seems like they're trapped they no one ever
gets injured it doesn't really feel like there's
any weight behind any of these moments no and I
I feel like if granted you could still do those
things but if it was coupled with something like
maybe the thing they're they're fighting has to
do with like some uh character Arc they have to
go through like maybe it's some mirror version of
like something of the character's experience or
the character gets injured like they're put in a
situation where they have to overcome something
but it never really got to that point never it
just kind of the same thing over and over and they
were safe there was no Stakes there was no there
was never any problem solving yeah to just running
it's just it's here get away from it yeah you know
there's no real thought on defeat like the only
way to defeat them is you got to open the book
you know and but there's no way to escape the situ
it would have been more more fun if there was per
character if there was something you had to do to
like like RL Stein What do we do to get out of the
situation it's like all right is this thing like
it's a trap of the werewolf like how do we get
the werewolf get out of it's but just everything
just goes back to run away from it and get away
yeah that could have been interesting like with
him being the writer if he knew every Monster's
weakness I could have added to the scenario yeah
that way it's not just repetitive and it so just
does become repetitive and there's no real and the
character stuff they just like heavy Exposition
like sprinkle in some heavy Exposition once in a
while to get whereas I thought like I was actually
enjoying that before the Goosebump stuff happened
that's that's the weird part like I was actually
really enjoying the first like half hour before
the Goosebump [__] started kicking in of this
guy moving to this town and a friending this girl
and then there's like the weird neighbor in the
mystery of the neighbor and then like oh is she
getting killed upstairs like there was it was it
was really fun actually yeah and it's when the
actual plots happened where it it kind of just
it's like a car that just speeds to 100 and then
starts losing gas really fast yeah and it just but
it's still speeding on the freeway the entire time
yeah no I agree with that I think that yeah also
the humor in the latter half of the movie wasn't
working as well for me cuz especially those like
bits with like the the mom and the the teacher
that kept popping up and then I never found a
champ funny at really any point really annoying
yeah right like he was like really annoying that
character normally works in like is he an adult
now so I can make fun of him I mean it's like
eight years ago so take itan probably be an
adult now right yeah he was annoying If this
just came out today I would be like we should go
soft he's a kid he's an adult now he should to
take the cyber bully he's a grown ass man I've not
seen this kid in the movie since I am impervious
to being coms and cyber bullying so let me let
me lay it on you for your performance years ago
roast [__] this kid no he's it is an annoying
but there's no I I don't blame him I I think I
think he's act I'm not just saying it to like
save face you I think he's actually believable
able as that character I think the character is
annoying um he's not like charmingly frightened
it it doesn't I think there's a thing there is
the beat there where he rises to the occasion
and saves the girl because he's so afraid but
but the movie's so busy with its repetitive set
pieces that you don't get time to really latch on
to I'm not even asking we're not asking for like a
deep character study or some [__] I'm just like
talking Basics here just Basics enough to get you
latched onto the adventure at hand and uh yeah
like by the time he even saves a girl I didn't
even register till right now like oh there it is
he's overcoming his fear I guess oh yeah like the
moment oh yeah yeah I guess what he was doing
but like I don't think you like added anything
to the movie like no there like when they were
when they were a trio and they didn't really
feel like a group necessarily it felt like the
the main character the girlfriend ARL Stein and
then he was just there yeah yeah yeah I like the
I like the the two like I actually felt really
bad for the girl when she was like getting did
she was getting ghosted yeah they created like
an this interesting conflict that they resolved
immediately and I was like oh I would have liked
if we like at least would have let that linger
until the second movie teach this thing about
loss you know it's like a doctor who Cliffhanger
yeah whenever the episode has a cliffhanger
how will they get out out of the situation
prologue of the next episode they are out of
the situation anyone who wants to start Doctor Who
I'm preparing you right now that is most of Doctor
Who yeah man I mean yeah I haven't seen dror
who in a minute but you're not wrong that is
the general structure Dr oh no Cliffhanger
I got to tune in next week oh good thing I
tuned in for that opening scene cuz they are
now out of that Peril on to the next situation
good for them right um but yeah I mean it's
just it's a movie that I think does it could it
warrants I don't think you I think you could ask
for more creativity from a movie that is about a
dude who is super creative like you can you it it
does it does feel like it other than just member
berries for Goosebumps which is kind of weird
considering that like sure it was a popular show
but a lot of people don't remember the show and
then the books it's that's a form of literature
so make these characters come to life the the
creatures come to life in a way that's truly
distinguishable or you you really see um something
like you need you need some type of implementation
of getting visually creative or some or setpiece
creative yeah I mean as we're talking about this
I'm kind of wondering who is this movie for is it
to intr ucing kids to a newer audience but then
I little kids and people who read Goosebumps but
even the kids who like Goosebumps right wouldn't
they want something that's more spooky to invoke
the experience of what they went through as a
child I don't know might be good enough we eat
up member berries in our society you know how
we are true we're Nostalgia based culture that
just loves everything that is just I know that
I mean people I do it sometimes people didn't
like uh Space Jam 2 and that was all member bar
that wasn't really member berries no that was all
IPS it wasn't really me member berries work more
in the sense of uh of like the world that it's
living in not IP not that is just like Warner
Brothers properties right but it's not a real
world um but this is like a world of of of like
the Goosebumps books you know or like Star Wars
does their memberberries and Mar Marv and you know
they they they're weaker now to us though they
don't work as strong on us anymore M don't we've
we've built up resistance we expect quality now
I know bunch of [__] yeah [__] trash I miss
just watching something and going I know that
thing I'm happy I'm satisfied as a man I'm you
did something I [Laughter] know I'm bricked up uh
yeah I think honestly they should have they should
have just like paired it down to a few things
instead of like a bunch of things yeah yeah and
and then they would have they they streamlined it
because it's like their load early by doing all
of them yeah so much yeah so much and I'm telling
you guys I I I still over like the first half I I
was really enjoying and then the last half be I
was a real intermittent experience for me so I
still Edge my way towards if this was Rotten
Tomatoes I would still be fresh okay I would
still be fresh I just I just barely cross the th
it's like when you you go to the store and you
go are these bananas actually still good well
there's no black spots on it yet so all right
I guess I'll go get them just got to make sure
to eat it within three four days probably sooner
yep or it's going to make you sick or else it's
going to oxidate fast yeah that's Goosebumps the
movie to me Goosebumps the movie Just Like Old
bananas just like bananas that are about to go
bed I mean yeah man it's the chair man it's the
armrest it's the armrest of a new attitude now
you're so cool thought I got a wave a pen around
now so your body language it does everything for
you yeah man makes you calm make you chill um
yeah man I thought it was a [Music] six we're
passing 645 out of kindness for me all right
guys what would you rate Goosebumps the movie
uh leave your thoughts down below when do you
decide do you buy bananas when they're really
green because it's like there's like that sweet
spot for a banana you know like they need to be
like they need to be yellow but when they're green
I don't like the taste of that some people like it
that way really they're not sweet enough I know
they're hard too yeah go eat your hard bananas
you yeah you do something else with hard bananas
you wait for them to go yellow what do you said
that's what you do baby anyway guys I'm ready
to shout out this Patron so I can get Aon out
of here Daddy pancakes who are you Danny pancakes
my God I think this is the first time I don't know
if John shouted you out last month is this your
first month getting a patron of the day shout out
no whoa oh I think you've just upgraded to or no
I don't think I've ever seen your name before Am
I Wrong Am I a jerk right now for not Danny
pancakes okay we're g to shout you out right
now Danny um Danny pancakes you uh I want to feed
you a bunch of steaks I'm going to go to your lawn
and all those leaves are going to get raked and
then we're going to take out a cake and have it
be baked and we can bake some pancakes and while
we're at it we can put some protein powder into a
shake so you're getting a little bit healthy then
they start calling you healthy Danny and then I'll
slap you on the bed the Buns you go Danny Fanny
and then you're going to get get me cancelled
cancel gregy Danny cancel gregy oh [Music] shitty
it's the movie Man SC put me in a weird mood super
chill it's the armrest it's the armrest dude
Danny pancakes Danny Danny pancakes shouting
them out oh come on ER I'm trying what the hell
I'm I'm a written man listen I like freestyling
but I'm I'm a written man what the hell I'm a man
of the the script not a script but like I'm a poet
for those of you guys who don't know Danny Danny
you're a great guy I love you Danny special man
dude here's what we're going to do we're going
to use chat gbt right now all right write me a
poem a rap for Danny pancakes make sure every
line rhymes with Danny pancakes let's see what
you do let's see if you can talk me chat gbt me
all right Aaron Danny pancakes staing knacking
up them Hot Cakes flipping them high no room for
the mistakes with syrup and butter no fake hand
shakes say fad yeah yeah D breakfast Kingpin
Watch the Throne he takes the chorus oh my god
there a chorus Danny pancakes serving them up
no breaks eat every bright you take feel like a
dream that awakes griddle on fire every morning
he bakes love the breakfast love the hot cakes
there's no hot in there that's okay Maple and
berries with whipped cream Lakes flavor so fly
give you taste but Quakes don't know in the diner
you don't know Daddy pancakes is a Pur she reming
about pancakes let's go in the diner with every
move he makes legend in the kitchen sets high
stakes Danny pancakes all right that's that's
enough all right we did it we did the thing damn
CH gbt is gonna replace us slowly but surely
this how Drake's been writing his RS all oh
100% know it all right we're done you did
it thanks Danny for being here [Music] h